[Applause]
[Music]
hey you guys
it's tuesday tuesday we're trying to
recover from last night yeah we're
running a little bit late today well
that's we ate kind of late and then i
was watching a movie and i wanted to
finish it so made some tortillas did
some tacos yeah they were delicious yeah
amazing
you got your uh your
turn the volume off on this just yeah
it's just really just got the dough
going to make hamburger buns
oh we're gonna have that later for like
for dinner that'd be good yeah i'm
throwing out hamburger and and i got the
dough sitting there rising to make some
hamburgers look at you mr
that's
baker
and it's kind of has eggs in it
egg hamburger bun oh okay i thought
it sounds good actually yeah
all right so uh you want to talk about
alien versus alien vs predator now you
had never seen this before no i've seen
it oh i thought i thought you told me i
haven't seen this version of it this is
uh what are they called directors or
unraveled the unrated version i think
the original one was pg-13 oh was it
okay although i don't really remember
anything different in this one although
like i said i saw this in the theater
when it came out back in 2004
and
it didn't really make any impressions so
i can't but it didn't really seem all
that graphic or gory or anything like
that to be honest this movie didn't make
an impression on you no you saw it in
the theater yeah yeah i liked it it's
all right i mean it's kind of
controversial the alien versus predator
scenes i mean
some of the mega fans [ __ ] hated this
one especially
the uh uh part two which is requiem yeah
i've heard yeah everybody shits on that
[ __ ] on that one and i haven't seen it
though i've seen it i've seen that one
too now there's a couple different edits
of it we're gonna uh we're gonna try to
get the uh the newest at it
um
i got opinions about that movie too i
mean you know i'm going to say that you
know
i kind of liked them
there are problems there's problems with
both of them
uh but it's just more alien and predator
stuff um
biggest complaint about this one that i
can recall
is that
the lead the lead in it is this uh chick
who's a uh she's i guess like a mountain
climber kind of like a they hired her as
like a survival guy survival guide
and she's a bit of a mary sue i mean she
can kind of you know everything she does
is [ __ ] awesome that's the only major
gripe with it besides that you know
there are some kind of inconsis you know
it kind of not really inconsistencies
there are there are there's some kind of
some cheese in it like you don't really
need a guide
uh they they brought a lot of people
weyland is bringing a lot of
professionals that he actually doesn't
need to have
or professionals that aren't rare
you know like yeah you can bring a guy
but there's thousands of those and you
don't really need a guide i mean you can
see where you're going
they just landed on top of it
it was just kind of an excuse to get uh
a bunch of different people
in the cast so you could have a an
action movie so they could all get
killed
that's really what it was
okay well it's just it's it's the same
principle as like a slasher movie it's
like you know the more teenagers go
along to the camping trip right the more
carnage will ensue right you know i'm
not going to argue so that does kind of
disturb the the the the the logic in the
movie uh but it's just a [ __ ] movie
all right could it have been better yeah
it could have been a lot better all
right
but it also could have been a lot worse
this [ __ ] is like a masterpiece compared
to some of the [ __ ] they've been
making in the past [ __ ] five ten
years
uh you know
i think it's better than the predator
which
has some
good in it and some bad in it you know
um that movie could have been a lot
better
so uh
now that it's kind of aged
it's not as it's not as bad as the they
thought it was i think at the time it's
just kind of
storyline is just kind of average
but it's got a lot of good scenes in it
got a lot of good special effects good
ideas uh it's a pretty cool story
i enjoyed it
it kind of reminded me of
because like when they go like if you
haven't seen the movie the the story
actually the or i guess the idea for
like the predator alien like teaming up
that came from like a comic book from
the late 80s yeah and i think like in
predator 2 wasn't there kind of like a
throwaway joke where the pr where he had
like an alien skull well because they
were kind of like yeah well they show in
the in the predator ship there's a
there's a piece of alien skull in there
and yeah
dinosaurs and stuff right they look like
dinosaurs so i so they've been like
kicking around uh you know ideas for
this for a long time and i think like
james cameron and ridley scott were kind
of like involved and then
when they said they wanted to do like
monster mash-up like predator versus
alien they're like nah i'm out um
although uh james cameron i think he i
think yeah james cameron like he saw
this movie later and was like that was
pretty good uh ridley scott was like no
absolutely not
so he you know he went on to make
prometheus like out of the ideas that he
had that were originally gonna be
this movie like a fifth or fifth alien
movie yeah so uh yeah so this was
directed by paul w s anderson who does a
lot of these kinds of movies he did like
the resident evil stuff and he does like
a lot of video game adaptations that's
kind of like his bag well [ __ ] that's
his bag then this is a masterpiece for
him
that suck
yeah those things could be very bad but
this movie's not bad it's yeah it's this
isn't a bad movie by any stretch um to
me it just seemed like there
like it's it's kind of enjoyable when
you're watching it but like i said i saw
it in the theater and i did not remember
i think the only thing i remembered
about it when we were re-watching it was
that big tunnel like them sliding down
the big long tunnel like into the earth
i remembered that and i think that was
about all that i remembered from it i
don't know why that was the only scene
that i remembered
but
okay one thing i will give it props for
is um pretty much all of the creature
effects are practical most of them yeah
they look good uh so it still looks
really good nowadays there is some cg in
there um mostly i think the cg was
mostly utilized uh when the monsters are
like kind of running around or also
because
this uh thing that's under the earth is
kind of like a tomb raider game yeah
where yeah where you kind of like fall
into the thing and like it closes up
like different yeah excuse some
background i mean you have wayland
weyland industries you know he's from
the from the alien franchise mega
billionaire you know
um
i do like that they got lance
hendrickson to play him yeah who played
bishop in the first right so i guess
whalen made all the robots look like him
yeah i guess that was like so i was like
oh that was pretty clever um
yeah and that that theme happens i think
in alien three too
yeah you meet him and he looks like
which we don't know how old [ __ ] uh
wayland is he must be [ __ ]
living centuries or something from like
biotechnology maybe he's downloading his
mined into [ __ ] clone bodies you know
replacement bodies which
man that's not that doesn't
sound
far-fetched anymore with some of the
weird technology they have now but um
anyway with his satellite one of his
satellites picks up this damn thermal
signal in antarctica and they analyze it
he has a team that analyzes it in 3d and
they see it's a damn
pyramid
2 000 feet underneath the [ __ ] dice
and it's a pyramid that looks like
mixtures of egyptian and
mesoamerican and uh
uh
looking top stuff from like a thailand i
feel like look at something from
thailand
and uh he gets together this team
of a team of kind of like explorers
and they're gonna go down there and look
at this thing
and uh
they brought drilling equipment and
everything
so
that part of the movie is actually feels
a lot like prometheus there's a lot of
this li i think a lot of those scenes
were kind of rehashed for the prometheus
movie yeah it might have been i i kind
of think that one of the ideas from this
came from chariots of the gods obviously
uh so you know prometheus kind of had
that sort of vibe too so which a lot of
people hated for me this i loved
prometheus because when i saw it i knew
something was missing that [ __ ] had been
cut out and and it was i saw the deleted
scenes and it was even better
but it still
prometheus was still kind of like now
what does this mean you know other
people were blowing it off but there's
too many down really scott hits you know
about rubik's cubes that was a puzzle
and then eventually the the original
script leaked and the original script
was so badass they should have made that
movie but they cut all the cool [ __ ] out
of it
[ __ ] [ __ ] um
and then
that really [ __ ] up prometheus
prometheus should have been really good
had they not [ __ ] with it
anyway
so they go down there to go
drill into this [ __ ] ice to go find
this temple and it turns out the damn
predators
shot a damn beam and board
bought a hole in the ice right down
right down to it just in a few seconds
they didn't see that happen though
they saw they saw that it cut through a
building because this is happening
underneath the old 1800s like a whaling
whaling village village yeah which kind
of and it showed
it showed a scene back in the 1800s so
this dude getting killed by the damn
predator and an alien that kind of i
liked it because it kind of gave the
what the hell that's my phone jesus
christ every time it rings he asks what
it is even though it's the same sound
yeah it's my phone right here yes spooky
ass music back there by the way thank
you mr roboto what do you say uh tom
could you survive alien versus predator
no i don't think i don't think nobody
could
that's the part of the [ __ ] of this
movie no you could survive around those
things
and um
so that first opening scene back in the
1800s was pretty cool because it kind of
gave me that cosmic horror kind of feel
like lovecraft yeah it was like a love
it had a kind of a lovecraft feel to it
that town you know
kind of like insmooth or something you
know anyway uh
so they go down in there and they see
this damn pyramid
and uh a couple of the guys there can
read
the glyphs to varying degrees
and uh they don't know exactly what's
going on but this thing is damn machine
and it changes shape while you're in
there it's a hunting ground
and underneath there they got a damn
alien queen and they can make eggs and
there's a damn sacrificial chamber that
they find and
there's this big backstory you know the
the predators have a dab hunting ground
on antarctica from thousand years ago
and uh every now and then
young predators have to go there
to survive this hunt
but against the aliens they call them
serpents the predators call them
serpents
and they have to fight the serpents
and
if they live they earn the right to
carry them down guns
on their shoulders like you saw them
predator that's how they earn them and
uh then the games begin they get in
there and [ __ ] of course
people get turned into aliens and chess
bursters and face huggers and
you gotta fight all of them aliens and
predators and it kind of narrows down to
them
the guide the chick who's a guide i
don't know that that actress's name
she's kind of like a
looking
mixed race kind of
black chick [ __ ]
i've seen her okay um killer figure man
those [ __ ] snow pants she's running
around here
that's just got some dyes on her man
bottom snow pants she's cute
but she's the berry sue the character
the character's not written that well
um
this is a problem if you ask me with all
the damn
alien movies
all of them including prometheus
because
the character of ripley was so badass
they keep trying to replicate that
character over and over again
they have some woman in there and she's
just gonna be a ripley ripoff
and you can only do that once that was
sigourney weaver that did that yeah a
certain place at a certain time
so one of the problems with anything and
having to do with the alien or alien
versus predator is that there's always a
fake ripley
which it gets old
but she did a good job of the movie you
know just you know this is this is the
story they want to tell
and uh she ends up uh
falling in with one of the predators
and she kind of becomes his hunting dog
basically
and he he teaches her how to survive the
damn aliens and he makes a shield and a
spear out of damn alien body parts
you know
it's kind of cool there's some kind of
cool ideas it's just
there's cheese you know she had a spear
and a shield made out of alien body
parts
that's not a survival for a success i
mean that's not a [ __ ] recipe for
survival against against [ __ ]
xenomorphs if you ask me
those things that kill you better than
[ __ ]
i mean they were killing people that had
[ __ ] machine guns yeah and body armor
so
kind of strange credulity but
it did have some good fight scenes and
it had a good ending
and i don't want to i get you know this
old movie you know
i guess i could spoil it probably
everybody's seen it
the the predator she makes friends with
uh gets pregnant
by her knocking gets pregnant
by the aliens
and at the end
that would actually be better
if they have sex
they should have me writing this [ __ ] i
could write this [ __ ] man those [ __ ]
movies would be badass and the asses and
sheets and [ __ ] everybody come see my
movies it'd be [ __ ] bizarre
bizarre yeah
he had like a gender swapping gender
swapping predator he's now pregnant it
turned out the whole time he was female
or maybe in maybe the predators that's
the the males get pregnant
yeah that'd work you know we'll work it
out that's what i'm saying because there
are some animals there that happen pops
out half human
yes and them snow pants
you saw the snow pants
you saw the snow pants yeah
she had some badass thighs
that sounds fetish i think this stuff no
fetish eyes in the snow
[Laughter]
yeah
but uh yeah but so yeah the fight scenes
were cool like i really liked the
practical effects yeah um what criticism
i don't like some of the fight scenes
like the editing was too quick and too
close up i couldn't tell what was going
on you know what i mean yeah that's
because they're just
they're trying to make it exciting and
they don't want it to look fake so they
don't show it to you very long yeah
suggesting that they do that in predator
alien too in aliens a lot yeah a lot of
[ __ ] was just almost subliminal flashes
which that can work but i kind of feel
like but it was more i don't even think
it was the fast editing it was just that
i feel like the camera was a little bit
too close to the action yeah so when and
then when you have that fast editing
like that i'm like wait who what
you know what just happened like who
who's getting hit here
so it was that kind of thing and you
know like you said the characters in
this are not super
i mean she was obviously the best one
because she was the one that got like
the most screen time
but i didn't remember any of the other
characters names uh and you know the the
only other guy i kind of remembered was
like i was like the dude that was in
trainspotting
you know i was like hey you
trainspotting guy so you know
uh yeah
that was another thing that's kind of
about the movie is that uh you got your
standard
[ __ ] over masculinized
[ __ ] mary sue females and a lot of
[ __ ] corny males a lot of corny white
dudes
several of those
uh which is it's very predictable now
there's like
you can tell how certain thing is almost
everything's now a trope in these movies
it's all those [ __ ] tropes it's
there's not very much originality
in any of these things really it's like
they have to work within certain
frameworks it's because they're
assembling this [ __ ] by committee and
everything is about
[ __ ]
law of averages and [ __ ] well what is
the and it's it's it's it's
they they put these movies together i
think by a theory you know theorem or a
[ __ ] algorithm
and it looks canned
they don't
they don't feel natural
to me
but
it was still an entertaining movie if
you're real drunk it's even better
yeah yeah and you just i don't take this
[ __ ] serious i don't take these movies
seriously anymore well i don't either
but that's the thing is like they're the
fandom
from all these properties they [ __ ]
love these things and a lot of it has to
do with the video games
and uh expanded universe stuff and books
they love the [ __ ] but the people that
make these movies don't really give a
[ __ ] they they're they're just going to
put it together according to what the
studio wants and it's just going to be
kind of corny
and when it comes out the hardcore fans
are like oh you know it's
because you have [ __ ] up their sacred
their sacred [ __ ] story you know
which i i agree
look at how bad they [ __ ] up star wars
you know
i understand it it's just that you're
not gonna be able to control it not
until you start voting with your feet
stop [ __ ]
watching this [ __ ]
and they're not gonna stop watching it
they'll watch anything seems like
mr roboto says jenny is that natural
sunlight behind you yes it is yeah uh
coming through there yeah i was i i was
just thinking too it's probably in a
couple minutes it's probably going to
come and like
white out the screen because i forgot
that it does that around this time of
day
uh
hello my favorite goth couple hello
hello chat i remember when this movie
was being advertised people were so
upset that it got dropped from a rated r
to pg-13 yeah and i think that was that
they initially made it as an r movie but
i guess the studio you know the i kind
of feel like in the early 2000s they did
a lot of that like horror movies and
stuff which is why i didn't like a lot
of them um they're just like well you
know more teenagers will go see it if
you make it pg-13
so they usually had to like cut a bunch
of stuff out but the version that we saw
we saw the unrated one
which was on uh amazon prime
yeah and
it felt good
yeah but yeah i didn't really um but i
didn't know what would have been taken
out to give that a pg-13 probably a
couple seconds of gore
and it wasn't really that gory i mean
honestly even when the people got killed
it wasn't gory and then the monsters
like when the monsters were fighting
each other that it was like green blood
and you can get away with green blood
all day long because it's a killing a
monster yeah
so i don't really know i don't even
remember there being like excessive
swearing in it or anything like that so
i'm really i i'm struggling to think of
like what was cut out of that to make it
a pg-13 it didn't really seem all that
graphic to me we're doing these because
uh a couple years back i remember a
regular had asked me
for to review these well they wanted to
know my opinion on them so we'll be i'm
gonna give you my opinion
we're gonna do requiem too
requiem had
problems but i also enjoyed it but we'll
talk about it more see i haven't seen i
haven't seen that yeah i saw this but
like i said it didn't i remember seeing
it in the theater and being like ah that
was okay yeah and then not ever thinking
about it ever again you know what i mean
i had forgotten like everything that
happened in it
um
but as i said other than it's not a bad
movie it's just not real
memorable like it didn't really stand
out to me
i think the reason why it's not
memorable is it does not have an organic
feeling
alien one and two and they evidently
they james cameron hates it when people
call it alien too but [ __ ] you i'm gonna
call it alien too i don't have time to
[ __ ] put an s on something all right
but he has time for this whole long
explanation about it though
so she's trying to call me out behind it
okay
well yeah that's that's my job alien one
and two kind of had a realistic tone to
it you had uh characters that seemed
very believable
um the
uh they did seem like
you you bought it that they were
basically [ __ ]
space truckers
you know blue collar space he bought it
and then
people go into a damn abandoned [ __ ]
compound on another planet with uh the
colonial marines
and in the original edit you kind of buy
that the characters do seem realistic if
you see the extended director's cut of
[ __ ] alien 2 there's too much hudson
in there and too much some other ones
and hudson is a goofy character if you
see everything that they did
everything that he says it's better that
they cut a lot of him out he's better
but there's less of him because what was
in what was in the original theatrical
release
it was the best of hudson
he didn't want anymore he was just goofy
um
also the the stuff that was happening
on
at hadley's hope
before they got there like what the
colonists did it's better if you don't
know what they did you just show up what
the hell happened to them you have to
imagine what they did in the director's
cut it shows newt's family and that they
found the the alien ship it does the
edit doesn't it doesn't look that good
what what was shot
and just the stuff at the
the stuff at hadley's hope
it's better if you don't know
because then there's more tension
into the movie you know i mean you're
like wow what happened here you know you
only want to know what the marines know
basically
yeah like [ __ ] like that's way scary it
might scare you if you don't know
because you're going into it on the same
footing as the protagonist exactly so
the the
out of uh when it comes to alien 2
you want to see the theatrical release
that's the standard that's the best one
later on once you get used to it you can
watch the director's cut see the bonus
[ __ ] because you already know you know
what i mean so you get to see what was
what was shot and some of the scenes
that were deleted
well
abp did not have that kind of
organic kind of gravitas
as the theatrical releases of one of
aliens one and two
and the same thing with predator
predator one predator two is okay not as
good as one
i actually liked
the uh what was it called predators
yeah i like that as well i liked that as
well yeah when they were on the alien
planet the hunting planet i really liked
that one i thought that one was really
good yeah the one with adrian birdie in
it yeah yeah i like i thought it was
good yeah it wasn't perfect adrian brody
you got the [ __ ] batman voice and uh
you know but
and every every character in there is
kind of a reboot of another character
that's all right
i thought that was a good movie
predators
i thought it was a good idea you had
[ __ ]
crazy ass nuts like me from the va
fighting predator
but
they didn't quite do that as well as it
is it could have
been you know oh
it was okay
but they they demystified too much of
the damn
predator
adding this stuff in about gene splicing
and
uh
[ __ ]
global warming [ __ ] you know
just kind of distracted from it no
leave leave the yawtas or whatever you
call them leave them alone they are that
they're not trying to cross breed
themselves with [ __ ] prey with their
prey i thought that was a dumb idea um
you could probably take you could
probably take the predator that last one
and re-edit it and make it a lot better
that movie just needed to be streamlined
some
remember
yeah kind of i don't know the kid the
kid that found the mask
the what do they call the
uh the little idiot savant kid what do
you call them
it's not an idiot savant what are they
called nowadays but it's autistic same
thing i'm old school man back in the day
we call them idiot savants idiot
geniuses
but the the uh the the autistic kid
was totally unnecessary to the movie he
should have been taken out of there i
don't know why he was in there
um i think maybe they were trying to
appeal to a younger audience so they'd
put a kid in it they put it they put a
candy in there basically if you guys
watch guys
camera gamer always had a little [ __ ]
japanese kid in shorts named kenny okay
it seemed like he was always kidding
yeah yeah who made friends with gamers
yeah gamer is friends all children
and also these studios that make these
movies are [ __ ]
they're they're they're stupid uh they
they overthink things they listen to
[ __ ] study groups well putting a kid
in a movie is kind of like a quick way
of getting people to
uh you know in theory anyway uh getting
people to getting people to care because
it's just kind of like oh a child in
danger like most people would you know
it's all theory it doesn't actually work
well it depends on how well it's
executed i mean that's true
uh i mean you could kind of say elite a
battle angel was that
that people you could yeah that
character's making you care because
she's young and she doesn't know what
the hell's going on
where am i you know but that was a very
good execution even though they don't
even know the audience loved it and they
don't want to make another one swipe
because they're [ __ ] [ __ ] all
right they're [ __ ]
the uh they'd rather make another the
predator and put like two candies in it
this time oh they'll respond this time
let's put two kids in it
you know i'd watch it if the predator
pulled both those kids heads off yeah
then i'd be like oh ballsy
studios i believe are run by just uh
groups of people that are paid to go in
there and give opinions uh based on some
piece of paper that they earned in some
[ __ ]
college oh well you know we have to have
this and that and oh and it'll sell
billions of tickets because people this
and that and then they just sell these
[ __ ] hokey ideas to some studio
cha-ching they get their check and they
walk off and then they just make this
damn abomination of a [ __ ] movie and
you could just tell just as artificial
as [ __ ]
what people responded to
was [ __ ] that was creative and artistic
and innovative and that's what
alien 1 and alien 2 were that
predator
predator 1 and 2 were predator one was
like that predator two not so much
uh and then the terminator terminator
one man that [ __ ] was [ __ ] bad ass i
didn't like 292.
a lot of people said well that's the
best action movie and go back and look
at that thing yeah
yeah oh well the thing about it i was
talking to matt at the club last night
about this we were talking we got into
this big long discussion about horror
movies because we were talking about
alien versus predator
and i was just kind of like the problem
is that
particularly with sci-fi and horror like
monster movies and stuff like that the
more
times you know the more times you return
to that well that same ip yeah it's it
becomes less and less mysterious and so
less and less cool yeah you know what i
mean so it's just kind of i mean
obviously the first alien the first
predator that was like [ __ ]
mind-blowing because nobody had seen
a monster like that you know what i mean
and you could buy it
you know what i mean yeah particularly
we were talking about this last night
too like the first predator like when he
takes that mask off and that [ __ ]
amazing
uh makeup you know what i mean i mean
that still looks [ __ ] great today
that mask from predator one looks better
than the mask in this one yeah it looks
a lot better yeah um and this was
decades later that's how good that damn
costume was yeah it was [ __ ] really
good it i mean it's still amazing and so
like i said once you've
seen that monster whether it's alien or
predator
um you know the more movies they make of
it it's like well everybody's seen that
now so you've already you've
automatically lost like
50 to 75 percent of what made the first
movie cool was that mystique and that
and that sense of the news you're seeing
something like different that you
haven't seen before and it's like you
don't have that anymore i know that
people in general and this is why they
keep making marvel movies that's why
they keep making sequels and reboots and
everything like that because people
actually do respond to
seeing something familiar um
you know a lot of times if somebody
makes some weird ass bizarro movie like
nobody wants to watch it
uh so there is a reason why they keep
doing it because people keep going to
see it people do like familiar things
but
honestly it's but then it's weird
because it's like they want to see more
of that but then they complain about it
it's like well they want more of that
but then when you give them more of that
they go oh that's how it is i didn't
like that
you know what i mean yeah but you know
that's just
that's the name of that game and they uh
they're dumb for falling into that but
maybe not that dumb
because they probably make a lot of
money doing that well yeah they do
obviously that's why they like i said
they just want to keep doing it and it's
like i don't understand like why but
each time it's diminishing returns yes
diminishing returns each time because uh
[ __ ] the predator
didn't do well at the box office
that last one yeah it didn't do well
uh yeah there's sorry there was like
some comments back here that were yeah
like for some reason i i got
i got booted out of [ __ ] youtube i
can't get back into it
oh youtube's sick of your [ __ ] yeah
get off yeah they're mad at you yeah
maybe maybe your thing is just [ __ ] up
yeah i don't know what it is but uh
yeah somebody was saying earlier that
yeah if you um you can make as gory a
movie as you want as long as you make
the blood green and then then you can
get away with it like pg-13 what was
that movie it's goddamn it what and i
there was a movie that was like that
that i was like specifically thinking of
where
it was just like slime instead of blood
and it made it green and it's just like
really really gross but it's still got a
pg-13 rating because it's not actual
blood you know what i mean the uh one of
the uh
evil dead movies wasn't it
oh maybe
now i can't like think what it is or was
it yeah it doesn't matter yeah it
doesn't but i just they did that they do
yeah a lot but so so maybe why but like
i said this movie i don't know like what
they would have cut out because it
didn't really seem
even like the chess burster they did
that and it's just kind of like it
wasn't that gory it wasn't even as bad
as it wasn't as bad as the first movie
and somebody pointed out too that it's
like you know in the first movie where
you know he gets the facehugger and then
it's
a while like before the alien baby pops
out his chest yeah and this one in this
one it was like almost immediately like
five minutes yeah she like you know the
thing was on her face and then like it
fell off and died and then like a second
later it was like pow and his leg popped
out but it wasn't like that graphic is
what i'm saying so i don't really know
like what would have been taken out of
here nothing really looked all that
trying to see alarming what are the
people saying
and uh somebody also said that
uh the alien was
would be scarier than predator yeah
because i mean predator
is scary but he's like a humanoid
thing you know
so i presumably and they have technology
and language and everything like that so
presumably you could reason with it
potentially um the alien not so much
all right the best
that's the best kill with this one
that's with the thing with the net that
damn sharp net that was a good one
um
but uh yeah what jenny was talking about
how they keep trying to go back
into the same well over and over again
to make more cash but it's diminishing
returns and then they do stupid [ __ ]
like what they did the reason why the
terminator franchise is not worth it
it's not worth a spit you just can't do
anything with that anymore
is because they [ __ ]
they committed the cardinal sin of that
movie they showed you skynet
they should have never showed that
and it's when they showed skynet it was
just a vr
humanoid face and with a voice and it
had a mind and a personality you could
talk to it you can now vision what sky
dad is stupid they should have never
done that ever yeah i mean don't
demystify things
shit's much scarier if you keep it like
mysterious you don't know what it is and
you go oh okay skynet's a chick she's a
chick on a screen that's not no
skynet should have been almost an
insect-like [ __ ] ai
computer
intelligence and it would have had no
need to take any human form or even
speak to a human
it would it would be like you trying to
talk to an aunt why would you even talk
try to talk to an ad that's that's
that's the way skynet should have been
you should have never seen it it'd be
like the internet
you know you can't talk to the internet
it's like that
but they gave it a damn form
that's just a bad idea terrible
kind of like what they did with the
board like the borg queen bad idea there
should have never been a board queen
mr roboto says uh steven seagal versus
predator who wins
tammy says seagal he just sits on the
predator
[ __ ] the predator would jump predator
would jump down and [ __ ] grab cigar
by the head and go nah
push him off and walk away
that was no challenge
that's pretty funny yeah he'd be doing
karate chops and trying to do
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah that's really happening
grandpa's hammer said if anyone wants to
meet seagal he's at the shot show in las
vegas this week he goes every year walks
around and pesters all the gun
manufacturers for swag yeah
yeah that sounds about right that that
truck and he'd probably get back there
and try to take have pictures of himself
taken with the [ __ ] staff like he's
overseeing the development of weaponry
yeah
yeah they're doing what i told him to do
yeah this is a pistol i've been wanting
to make this pistol for 20 years they're
finally getting around and doing it
yeah you know the barrett 50 was my idea
i invented 50 caliber actually
yeah back in world war one
yeah
captain blairdo says was it the lore
that predator would not attack you if
you're
unarmed uh yeah but it but they also did
unarmed combat remember that's she was
fighting hand to hand with [ __ ] with
uh uh
um
arnold there in the first one
so they did
same thing same thing hunters do you
know we have primitive weapon season
you know my first kill of the club was
primitive weapon season was a 50 caliber
muzzleloader i think i got a picture of
it around here somewhere
i think i was about 15.
well in this movie in this movie doesn't
like the predator kind of grabs wayland
yeah and like scans inside and sees and
sees that he's got some disease or
whatever it was was it cancer yeah and
um so he's just like no so he doesn't
hurt him yeah throws him down because
that's that's what he would do to go
like i said it's not a challenge it's
not fair yeah
but you know i got that i can't get any
points off of him
but there's uh
this one getting back to this one it's a
decent movie it's decent uh it could
have been a lot worse it could have been
the predator that was a lot that was a
lot worse even though
the predator like i said could that that
last predator movie could have been
edited into something even better i have
it on blu-ray i actually want to see it
again uh i tried to re-watch it again
here in the hou at home
got about an hour into it and just kind
of like i
i'm just not really i don't really want
to see this and it just walked away from
it
even though i think it got better as it
went
the way some of those guys died was uh
pretty cool
uh one guy got his damn legs cut off by
the damn shield on the ship
um
there was just some
there was that that movie just needed to
be streamlined down into something that
was a better movie
um
having the predators talk
to each other and then letting us know
what they were saying with the subtitles
not a good idea
again that's that demystification thing
it's much creepier if you don't know i
mean they can talk to each other
obviously but it you know if you don't
know what they're saying that's like
yeah don't tell us don't tell us what
they were saying because then we can
like imagine we can imagine all kind of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that they're talking
yeah and i i don't know who makes these
movies anymore i don't understand it
they don't know they don't really
understand human nature or and how to
manipulate human nature
you never want to give the fans that
much information you want them to
imagine and fantasize about it about
what they said
you know yes it makes it a lot more
mysterious you know man they're talking
to each other which is i would say that
that was
one of the things that i liked about
avp2 the requiem
it showed inside the ships it showed
them doing certain things and it really
didn't explain it but you knew what it
was going on you could tell and it was
kind of
more interesting that way they didn't
have subtitles under anything
graham there's hammer which is a worse
way to die by the predator or mongolian
death box mongolian death well yeah
because that takes longer yeah
do you have a coffin
yeah the death coffin the death card the
death coffin is designed to crush your
soul
and your body slowly over a period of
years
to crush your mind to cause you to just
go insane you go insane but it doesn't
matter you're still in that [ __ ] box
yeah and then those walls crush and dead
and then you can't stand it and you go
insane because you're in the box but
going insane doesn't help you you're
still in that damn box
woo
yeah that would sound sure it would take
and then you'd try to adapt to it but
then you'd adapt to a form of insanity
but then you oh no i can imagine it
would be good
yeah
all right are you ready to wrap it up
yeah i'm getting real sleepy i need a
nap um but yeah cause we gotta we gotta
watch a movie tonight so we can uh
record the
retrospective
uh and tomorrow night is our regular
show okay which is gonna be
creepiest urban legends all right so i'm
looking forward to doing that one
because i really like urban legends so
i'm gonna you know i just picked a bunch
that i liked so i'm gonna cover a bunch
of those and i'm
rereading one of my uh
jan harold brunovanned books
uh to kind of get some ideas for that
hold on hugo says abb was too dark
couldn't see [ __ ] that was the idea
they did it
i didn't want you to see it because it
was very low budget movie
if you saw parts of certain parts of
those things you'd go oh man it looks
like [ __ ] so i think it's probably a
better choice let's just turn all the
lights off
kind of dark it'll just be a complete
dark movie
that's your imagination
it might as well be like a radio show
like from the 30s or something
all right so uh yeah uh thanks everybody
for dropping by thanks for super chats
and we will see you guys tomorrow
evening
bye